the first action we are announcing today
is the unsealing of an indictment
charging Russian oligarch Constantine
malife with sanctions violations
as indictment charges the treasury
Department previously identified
malefeth as one of the main sources of
financing for Russians promoting
separatism in Crimea and for providing
material support for the so-called
Donetsk People's Republic
after being sanctioned by the United
States malofef attempted to evade the
sanctions by using co-conspirators to
surreptitiously acquire and run media
Outlets across Europe
we are also announcing the seizure of
millions of dollars from an account at a
U.S financial institution which the
indictment alleges constitutes proceeds
traceable to malife's sanctions
violations
the justice department will continue to
use all of its authorities to hold
accountable Russian oligarchs and others
who seek to evade U.S sanctions
the second action we are announcing
today is a disruption of a global botnet
controlled by the Russian military
intelligence agency commonly known as
the gru
the Russian government has recently used
similar infrastructure to attack
Ukrainian targets
fortunately we were able to disrupt this
botnet before it could be used
thanks to our close work with
International Partners we were able to
detect the infection of thousands of
network Hardware devices
we are then able to disable the Gru's
control over those devices before the
botnet could be weaponized
today's announcements are part of a
series of actions that the justice
department has recently taken to disrupt
and prosecute criminal activity
associated with Russia
yesterday together with our German law
enforcement Partners we seized the
russia-affiliated Hydra darknet Market
the world's largest illegal Marketplace
on the dark web
we also filed criminal charges against a
Russian national who we allege
administered the Market's technical
infrastructure
and on the day before that again with
our International Partners we seized the
Tango a super yacht owned by Victor
vexelberg another sanctioned oligarch
with close ties to the Russian regime
on that same day we obtained seizure
warrants targeting the assets of several
additional sanctioned Russian Nationals
the justice department will continue to
work alongside our International
Partners to hold accountable those who
break our laws
threaten our national security and harm
our allies
in the last half an hour President Biden
has tweeted quote I may clear that
Russia would pay a severe and immediate
price for its atrocities in butcher
today along with our allies and partners
we're announcing a new round of
devastating sanctions